>> WELCOME BACK! MY GUEST
TONIGHT,
HE STARS IN HBO'S "GAME OF
THRONES", IT'S ABOUT TO
PREMIER ITS FIFTH SEASON.
>> YOU NEVER TOLD ME WHY YOU SET
ME FREE.
>> YOUR BROTHER ASKED ME TO.
>> YOU COULD HAVE SAID NO.
>> REFUSING THE KINGSLAYER
IS A DANGEROUS PROPOSITION.
>> NOT AS DANGEROUS AS RELEASING
ME. YOU RISKED YOUR LIFE,
YOUR POSITION, EVERYTHING,
WHY?  YOU ARE NOT FAMILY.
YOU OWE ME NOTHING.
>> I DIDN'T DO IT FOR YOU.
I DID IT FOR THE SEVEN KINGDOMS.
>> DRUNKEN DWARF WILL NEVER BE
THE SAVIOR OF THE SEVEN
KINGDOMS.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IN SAVIORS, I
BELIEVE MEN OF TALENT HAVE A
PART TO PLAY IN THE WAR TO COME.
>> Jon: KILL HIM!
PLEASE WELCOME BACK TO THE
PROGRAM, PETER DINKLAGE!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> HOW DID YOU GET THAT
STUDENT FILM I DID YEARS AGO?
>> Jon: IT WAS SENT TO US BY
SOME ANONYMOUS --
>> THAT WAS MY OWN WARDROBE.
>> Jon: WAS IT REALLY?
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: IT SEEMS VERY
COMFORTABLE.
>> Jon: WAS THAT SUEDE?
>> YES. AND CASHMERE.
>> Jon: IT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: HERE IS A TRIBUTE TO
YOUR CHARACTER.
THERE IS NOT A MOMENT THAT I
WANT YOUR CHARACTER TO --
>> TO DIE.
>> Jon: NO LIKE HE IS GOING TO
HIT THAT GUY IN THE HEAD WITH
THE BOTTLE.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: LIKE I JUST ALWAYS THINK
THAT YOU HAVE SOMETHING GOING.
>> THAT'S TRUE. LIKE BENNY HILL?
LIKE --
>> Jon: NOT HIT HIM IN THE
HEAD LIKE -- I MEAN HIT HIM
IN THE HEAD, LIKE YOU LIKE TAKE
A SIP OF IT AND LIKE IT TURNS
OUT TO BE LIKE FLAME POISON OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> RIGHT.
>> Jon: LIKE DRAGON POISON.
>> YEAH. I WISH.
BECAUSE I DRINK SO MUCH OF THAT.
>> Jon: ON THE SHOW?
>> WINE ON THE SHOW.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW, THE
SERIES NOW, IT VEERS A
LITTLE BIT AWAY FROM THE
BOOKS NOW, A LITTLE MORE --
>> IN A LOT OF WAYS, YES.
>> Jon: A LOT OF WAYS.
>> IN MANY WAYS, YES. A LOT OF
PEOPLE --
>> Jon: I WAS SURPRISED TO SEE
FOR INSTANCE, THERE IS NOW A BOY
WIZARD NAMED HARRY IN IT.
WHICH SEEMED A BIT OF A
DEPARTURE.
>> YEAH. YEAH.
THE WHOLE SEASON THIS YEAR IS IN
A RESTAURANT LIKE
"MY DINNER WITH ANDRE."
>> Jon: JUST YOU TWO SITTING
THERE TALKING.
>> JUST THE WHOLE TIME.
>> Jon: DOES, DOES GEORGE, DOES
HE EVER LIKE STOP BY AND BE LIKE
NO!
>> HE USED TO.
HE IS BUSY LATELY.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> HE IS WRITING THOSE BOOKS.
RIGHT?
I MEAN, MY HEART GOES
OUT TO GEORGE, BECAUSE BOY OH
BOY --
>> Jon: THAT'S A LOT.
>> THEY'RE JUST, THEY'RE HARD ON
HIM, THE FANS.
I MEAN, IT IS LOVELY BECAUSE
THEY WANT, THEY WANT THOSE
BOOKS, BUT, HEY, THEY HAVE
GOT TO EASE UP.
>> Jon: YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS TOO,
I THINK THAT THERE IS AN
INSATIABILITY AND ONCE PEOPLE
GET AHOLD OF IT LIKE, THEY DON'T
REALIZE THE PROCESS, LIKE
IT TAKES A LONG TIME,
AND A LOT OF ENERGY.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: TO CREATE THAT AND
WEAVE THOSE, AND THEY'RE VERY
COMPLEX AND VERY VIVID AND VERY
EXPLICIT.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: I IMAGINE THAT IS
DIFFICULT OR DO YOU THINK DOES
HE HAVE LIKE JUST A TEAM
OF LITTLE MINI MARTINS THAT ARE
JUST IN THE BACK ROOM JUST LIKE
-- JUST POUNDING AWAY?
>> PROBABLY.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> DON'T WE ALL HAVE THOSE? YOU
HAVE THOSE.
>> Jon: WELL --
>> RIGHT?
>> Jon: WE CALLED THEM
INDENTURED SERVANTS.
>> THEY ARE CALLED INTERNS.
>> Jon: THAT'S RIGHT. THEY'RE
CALLED --
DO YOU GUYS, DO THEY, I
TELL YOU THE --
>> YOU GUYS LAUGH
WHEN I SAY INTERNS.
I COULD SAY ANYTHING. IT'S
VERY LOVELY. YOU'RE SO SWEET.
>> Jon: TRY IT. TRY A WORD. JUST
TRY IT.
>> CATERPILLAR.
>> Jon: COME ON.
YOU WENT RIGHT TO CATERPILLAR?
THAT'S A FUNNY WORD!
THAT'S AN EXCELLENT CHOICE!
ARE PEOPLE GONNA, YOU KNOW, I AM
ALWAYS CONCERNED WHEN SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPENS THAT
TELEVISION JUMPS ON IT AND --
>> WHAT DO WE DO NOW.
>> Jon: CREATES, YES OR
CREATES BAD VERSIONS OF
THIS SIMILAR --
>> I THINK THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT
OF BAD VERSIONS BEFORE US.
>> Jon: RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT.
>> YOU KNOW, BECAUSE IT IS
REALLY HARD TO DO.
IT COSTS MONEY AND TV USED TO
NOT BE WHAT IT IS TODAY.
>> Jon: IT'S ALSO HARD I THINK
TO KEEP IT FROM BECOMING
PARODY. I THINK THAT'S THE MOST
DIFFICULT THING.
>> WE OFTEN MAKE IT PARODY ON
SET.
>> Jon: THE CHRISTMAS PARTY I
AM SURE GETS VERY --
>> OH, IT IS SUCH A FINE LINE.
IT IS SUCH A FINE LINE.
>> Jon: YES. BUT TO PULL THAT IS
NOT EASY.
>> NO.
AND WE'RE, I MEAN, ESPECIALLY
WORKING WITH CONLETH HILL,
WHO PLAYS VARYS, THE SPIDER, THE
BALD MAN IN THAT SCENE.
>> Jon: HE GETS A LITTLE, HE GET
INTO IT. YOU KNOW WHO ELSE?
>> NO, I MEAN, HE'S IT IS SO
MUCH FUN.
>> Jon: HOW'S MOUNTAIN? HOW'S
THE, HE --
>> THAT MAN, WE WERE HAVING
DINNER, I GOT TO EAT DINNER WITH
HIM ONE NIGHT IN CROATIA AND HE
ORDERED SEVEN CHICKENS.
HE ATE SEVEN CHICKENS.
LIKE WHOLE CHICKENS, LIKE
ROAST CHICKENS.
>> Jon: OH, SO THEY WERE COOKED?
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: THAT'S --
>> Jon: BUT HE, LIKE YOU READ
ABOUT --
>> JUST AN AMAZING
LOVELY GUY.
GIANT, HUGE.
>> Jon: HUGE. AND I READ --
>> YEAH. HE LIFTS STONES.
>> Jon: RIGHT.
>> HE BROKE -- THIS IS TRUE.
HE BROKE A 1,400-YEAR-OLD
STRENGTH RECORD.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: BY LIFTING -- I THINK
HE PUT IT ON HIS SHOULDER, A
30-FOOT TREE TRUNK.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: AND LIKE CARRYING IT
TO A 7-11.
>> TO HIS GIRLFRIEND.
>> Jon: I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
END WAS.
>> YEAH. YEAH.
>> Jon: DOES HE JUST PICK
THINGS UP LIKE A FLINTSTONE
CHARACTER? ON THE SET?
>> I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO PAY
HIM.
I THINK IT IS SORT OF, YOU KNOW
--
>> Jon: A LITTLE BIT OF A PARTY
FAVOR TYPE THING.
>> A LITTLE BIT. HE IS
PROBABLY SICK OF DOING IT
FOR HIS FRIENDS.
>> Jon: I LIKE THAT. I LIKE
THAT.
AND WHEN'S, THERE IS GOING TO
BE MORE, RIGHT?  SEASON SIX AND
THE WHOLE THING? OR IT DEPENDS
ON WHEN --
>> I DON'T KNOW WHEN I DIE OR IF
I DIE.
A WOMAN THE OTHER DAY SAID TO
ME, I WAS SORT OF HADN'T
HAD MY MORNING COFFEE YET.
>> Jon: YEAH.
>> AND SHE SAID I HOPE YOU DON'T
DIE.
AND I DIDN'T PUT IT TOGETHER
BECAUSE I WAS TIRED AND I'M A
WRECK BEFORE MY COFFEE
AND IT WAS SO WEIRD AND
IT TOOK ME A SECOND AND IT WAS
SO TERRIFYING.
>> Jon: THAT IS -- WERE YOU JUST
AT A RESTAURANT?
YOU WERE JUST AT --
>> I WAS WALKING ON THE NEW YORK
CITY STREETS AND SHE SAID IT TO
ME IN PASSING.
I HOPE YOU DON'T DIE.
I HOPE I DON'T EITHER. DO YOU
KNOW SOMETHING I DON'T KNOW?
>> Jon: I WOULD LOVE THAT IF
THAT IS JUST SOMETHING SHE DOES
IN THE STREETS OF NEW YORK.
>> YEAH.
>> Jon: JUST WALKS PAST PEOPLE
AND GOES, I HOPE YOU DON'T DIE!
>> BUT THE THING IS SHE IS
ALWAYS RIGHT BECAUSE WE ALL DO.
>> Jon: SHE IS LIKE THAT FILM
"THE RING."
>> RIGHT.
>> WHEN SHE SAYS IT TO YOU
LIKE SEVEN DAYS LATER YOU'RE
LIKE I DON'T FEEL WELL.
NEW SEASON, "GAME OF THRONES",
PREMIERS THIS SUNDAY AT 9:00,
HBO, THE GREAT PETER DINKLAGE.